foreign
[Music]
take a good look at this slug no not
that that's a leaf this slug there we go
Elysia clorotica may not look like much
okay it looks like a bright green leaf
but it's one of the most extraordinary
creatures around living in salt marshes
along the east coast of North America it
can go about a year without eating
during that time it lives like a heart
generally speaking animals are what are
called heterotrophs meaning they can't
produce their own food they're consumers
of other life plants meanwhile are
autotrophs or producers they can
synthesize their own fuel from sunlight
CO2 and other inorganic compounds plants
do this by using organelles called
chloroplasts which give them their
bright colors and convert sunlight into
food through photosynthesis Elysia is
what's called a mixatroph it can both
consume food like animals and produce
its own through photosynthesis like
plants in fact Elysia steals its ability
to photosynthesize from the algae it
eats by piercing the algal cells with
specialized pointy teeth called radula
it sucks the cell empty and digests most
of its contents but the chloroplasts
remain intact they're incorporated into
the epithelial cells lining Elysia's
digestive system that branches
throughout its flat body this makes the
slug look even more leaf-like providing
camouflage as well as food
as incredible as this adaptation is
there are more than 70 species of slug
that steal chloroplasts from their food
what makes Elysia and a few closely
related species in the Mediterranean and
Pacific unique is how long they could
hold on to chloroplasts most other slugs
keep them for a few weeks at most this
longevity seems to be due to the
survival abilities of both plastids and
slugs specifically the chloroplasts of
certain algae can repair their own light
harvesting systems While most
chloroplasts are thought to rely on
their host cell and its genes for
repairs this makes the chloroplasts able
to sustain themselves for longer inside
the slug meanwhile the slug adjusts its
gene expression to improve its
relationship with the chloroplasts and
removes damaged plastids to avoid
accumulation of potentially damaging
chemicals though few species can steal
organelles from another species cell
these slugs are far from alone in
getting an assist from Plants organisms
as diverse as corals giant clams and
sponges have symbiotic algae living
inside their cells supplying them with
organic compounds through photosynthesis
in turn they Supply their little helpers
with shelter and inorganic compounds
some of these mixotrophs even transmit
the algae to their offspring without the
aid of these algae filter feeding corals
clams and sponges would not gain enough
nutrition in the nutrient poor tropical
Ocean and the dazzling coral reefs they
build simply would not exist
atrophy even Cuts both ways an alga
called tripospherica can consume several
microscopic animals a day allowing it to
survive in darkness for weeks tripos is
in turn eaten by other mixotrophic algae
providing frequent opportunity for
exchange of organelles such as
chloroplasts this seems to allow some
algae to survive in parts of the dark
ocean such as the Mariana Trench which
plants otherwise wouldn't be able to
inhabit
the processes by which Elysia becomes
photosynthetic and tripos switches
between feeding modes are reminiscent of
what scientists believe led to the
origin of all plants single-celled
animals preyed on cyanobacteria some of
these tiny plants were not digested and
lived on in the animal cells eventually
giving rise to chloroplasts but these
first eukaryotic plants were soon
consumed by other animals which hijacked
the precious chloroplast just like
Elysia
and following the example of eating and
being eaten we've seen in the case of
tripods this chloroplast Heist happened
up to three times giving rise to
plastids with four membranes and the
ocean's most productive plants and
forests
this slug slash plant is just one of
millions of species that uses crafty
evolutionary adaptations to survive take
the Orchid just a pretty flowering plant
right wrong find out about their sneaky
tactics of deception with this video